jetzt auch noch lena genau diese frage
haben sich gestern sehr viele in den
sozialen netzwerken gestellt diese sind
regelrecht heiß gelaufen mit dem vorwurf
dass der popstar jetzt zu den corona
leugnen gehören soll
es ging um ein posting von nina indem
sie darüber schreibt dass die ganze
panikmache
die momentan hier in deutschland ist
über den wahnsinn und dass man doch mit
ihr ins licht gehen sollte
ziemlich kritisch der ganze post den wir
hier gerade von nina selber sehen und
was dahinter steckt darüber möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit meinem kollegen aus
unserem chanson hauke herbst ist bei mir
im studio
was ist da los gehört nena jetzt
tatsächlich zu den coruna leugnern
könnte man wirklich so glauben wenn man
das liest das ist auch welchen etwas
merkwürdiges posting was zu dieser zeit
natürlich viele fragen aufwirft
ich habe mit ninas ehemann und manager
gesprochen
vorhin und ihm lag wirklich am herzen zu
sagen dass nina kein kroner leugner ist
dass sie sich auf keiner der beiden
seiten sieht also wieder auf der seiten
der kritiker noch der krassen
befürworter der maßnahmen was aber eben
wichtig war für die beiden kein corona
leugner also deswegen nena gehört nicht
in das lager dass der michael wendlers
und co jetzt muss man sagen lena lena
ist seit ewigkeiten im geschäft kennt
die ganzen sache sehr sehr gut muss sie
nicht irgendwie klar gewesen sein was
daraus gemacht wird zumindest auf
twitter und co wenn sie solche dinge
schreibt ich würde sagen ja das kann man
ja auch vorwerfen
man muss ein bisschen dieses posting im
kontext sehen das bild was sie da
gepostet hat mit der fahne ist aus einem
video wandern aus ihrem aktuellen song
und ihr neues album heißt licht das
heißt du ich gehe ins licht ich lass
mich nicht in die dunkelheit ziehen das
ist auch das album gemünzt gewesen das
muss man dann noch ein bisschen dahin zu
ziehen
trotzdem ja ist es etwas unglücklich ein
solches posting zu der jetzigen zeit zu
machen man weiß aber eben auch nina hat
wirklich ihren eigenen kopf und postet
das dann was sie denkt und die intention
war allerdings von ihr positiv gemeint
das wurde mir nochmal so betont ans herz
gelegt dass sie einfach sagen will
möchte
lasst euch nicht in panik versetzen egal
von wem und lasst euch nicht kirre
machen er den kontext den wollen uns
vielleicht einmal anschauen und in die
musik die neue musik von nina einmal
rein um das ganze etwas besser zu
verstehen
na klar
[Musik]
von bärbel
das sagen
[Musik]
wir kommen lassen
und so sind allein
[Musik]
so klingt also die neue musik aber eine
sache bei dem posting ist trotzdem ich
weiß gar nicht ob das überhaupt noch als
unglücklich bezeichnet kann denkt sei
wenn du einer der bekanntesten kroner
leuten die wir hier in deutschland haben
hat das ganze im herz kommentiert und
nena hat sich da eben nicht distanziert
sondern mit einem eigenen herz darauf
geantwortet das ist ja wirklich gerade
in diesen zeiten sehr schwieriges
zeichen oder finde ich auch sie hat ja
auch noch einen song zitiert saver nadu
der song ist allerdings von 2005 also
sehr alt wurde sagt so wir müssen
zusammenstehen und zusammengehalten
wir haben natürlich auch dazu befragt zu
der beziehung und wie sie es selber
naidoo und seiner seinen thesen steht
wollte sie sich nicht äußern
wir wissen aber die beiden kennen sich
klar die waren häufig zusammen im tv
kennen sich auch schon lange ich glaube
nina wollte hier einfach jemanden den
sie sicherlich kritisch sieht aber den
sie von früher eben auch noch positiv
gesinnt ist nicht gleich eine abfuhr
erteilen ich finde es auch etwas und
konsequent weil es auch ein herzchen
like ist was sie ihn zurück gesendet hat
aber das glaube ich gibt marina einfach
so das ist meine privatsache
das ist jemand den ich halt von früher
kenne und sie hat sich ja nicht
hingestellt und gesagt der mann hat
recht
ich glaube das ist eine persönliche
sache dann also als fazit nina jetzt
nicht nachdem valve naidoo die nächste
in diesem lager sondern einfach ein
unglückliches posting auf instagram
kindern kauke für diese erklärung zu der
ganzen sache
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich je das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren